one of the biggest changes for the new
xbox one experience was the addition of
one guide or you know kind of way to
look at all your apt channels really
seamlessly all at once I ended up
watching a lot more TV than I expected
on my console so it's pretty cool that
it's kind of like more accessible now
they got movies I saw that crackle I
don't know if that is but that the raid
redemption on it for free this week yeah
they're leading more with the content
than they are with the app itself so you
might not know what sling is but it's
got movies on and it might be something
you've actually been wanting to watch
anyway so you'll see the content or like
the movie or TV show that might have
grabbed your attention all on this
homepage and they'll be organized by the
different app itself youtube sling
Microsoft TV vh1 amazon crunchyroll all
that stuff yeah I know it's one of those
things that'll learn who you are and
like your favorite stuff it'll like show
you when the next episode of quantico's
on the second thing is button mapping
this came out with the new xbox elite
controller but every xbox one controller
to now can continue to buttons on so if
you wanted to like to switch your Envy
buttons or what the sticks do you can
invert them for any game so you don't
need the option in game anymore so I
mean it's a nice little like quality of
life feature especially for people who
have like really strict ideas of what
button stays on I don't it makes a lot
of sense for the xbox elite control of
it it's just a nice touch to have for
the classic controller but the biggest
change for the new xbox one experience
has to be backwards compatibility which
just added 100 games from the xbox 360
now playable on the Xbox one over 100
games so anyone who bought fallout 4 kid
get fallout 3 for xbox 360 for free so
you just plug that in and now you can
play it like emulates all these 360
games on the Xbox on hardware but if
you're not a big fan of fallout 3 but
maybe you like yours for three you can
also play assassin's creed two
Borderlands fable two just cause to Mass
Effect and mirrors edge those are
something like really popular ones that
you'll see on there of course they're
going to come out with more games over
time they don't have red dead redemption
or black ops 2 which were the most
requested one but maybe they won't one
day who knows and will also find that
when they
their xbox gold games there's a lot of
360 games on there now you get those two
right yeah that's like double the free
games here is nice and then in addition
to that any games that you had
previously digitally or you still have
like the physical disk and it's on your
account now you get those back as well
so it is a huge feature cool so yeah the
upgrades available now you can get it
just from the home menu and there's a
bunch of other features as well but
these were our favorite three